في مضيق تايوان حيث تتصاعد التوترات بشكل
تدريجي ما ينظر بامكانيه حدوث مواجهه في
اي وقت فصين ماضيه في مناورات عسكريه حول
جزيره تايوان ردا على زياره رئيس التايوان
للولايات المتحده وعلى لقائها مسؤولين
امريكيين فاين بالتحديد التدريبات الصينيه
وما حجمها بحسب مصدر امني تايواني فان
التدريبات الصينيه تقع حول قناه باشي التي
تفصل تايوان عن الفلبين التدريبات الصينيه
تضمنت محاكاه لضربات دقيقه على اهداف
رئيسه في تايوان ولتطويق الجزيره بالكامل
وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه تقول انها رصدت
مقاتلات صينيه من بينها مقاتلات سوء 30
وقذفات h6 الى جانب احدى عشره سفينه حربيه
اخرى في محيط الجزيره من جانبها قالت
رويترز نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه ان المواجهه
باتت وشيكا حيث تتواجد عشر سفن صينيه
اضافه الى مثلها تايوانيه على خط المواجهه
بالقرب من الخط الاوسط للجزيره طيب اكدت
انها لن تسهم في التصعيد لكنها توعدت
بالرد بالشكل الملائم على تدريبات بكين
واشنطن حليفه التايوان من جانبها قالت
انها تراقب المناورات الصينيه عن كثب
مؤكده انها تمتلك ما يكفي من موارد وقدرات
لضمان السلام والاستقرار في المنطقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات